how are you doing I'm good good good
thank you so before we get to anything
else
Jacob Cain good guy bad guy come on
question well you know hope you've lost
that question he's ostensibly a good guy
but he has a lot of you know the history
that he that catches up with them
throughout the course of the the first
season you know he he's a leader of the
crews who and he is the the protector of
Gotham City he's not a fan of Batman
wasn't a fan of Batman Batman's
disappeared and he has taken upon
himself to be the the protector as it
were he doesn't trust sort of vigilantes
take us through this version of Gotham
because you mentioned Batman's been gone
for three years yeah okay so people who
we're all familiar with different
versions of Gotham yeah take us through
your version of god I would say that our
version of Gotham is quite dark actually
put I mean it says genre piece it's
comic burkas you know the the it's the
bat world does it work the Gotham Morrow
but it's quite a dark exploration of
that world because of the history and
and and you know because Jacob Kane was
mired to you know this woman and there
was a terrible car crash like 15 years
previously to the start of the series
and he lost one of his daughters one of
the twins and that's caused him a great
deal of pain and his other daughter has
you know been traumatized by that Israel
and that's Kate and so and of course
then Batwoman comes to the fore and who
is bat woman and his daughter Kate once
desperately - what with Jacob and he
doesn't want to work with her because he
wants to keep her out of harm's way but
she of course turns out to be a
fantastic warrior so he says well you
must come and work for me and she's like
no thank you it's too late I want to do
my own thing so then of course bat woman
appears in Gotham City Israel who Jacob
Kane is not a fan of because for him
that's the same as you know it's just
another pretender someone who you know
occasionally turns up and tries to save
the citizens of Gotham but he's much
more of a traditionalist he comes from
an army background he's a colonel in the
Army so he runs a very tight ship
his are his decisions sometimes
questionable and does he push the limits
sometimes absolutely of course he does
and for him the ends justify the means
but he's a very complex character as
they all are you know Caroline Reese who
wrote the series she's a terrific writer
really wonderful she's created these
wonderfully rich dark characters
ultimately with a lot of heart it's a
kind of family drama with the action and
the comic book around when we all found
out that ruby was cast as Batwoman
everybody collectively said the same
thing which is that makes total sense
yeah it does it does she's great I love
Ruby I mean as a person as a champion
she's got she's kind of perfect for bat
women because she's she's tough as a
kind of as a personality I don't mean
that in a negative manner sort of she
has great power as a personality and she
certainly knows who she is but she's
also got a great heart and a great
sensitivity which you need when you see
the story emerge about woman you you
understand why she is perfect to play
that character and she's funny as well
and rosy and opening this up to to other
audiences the other headlines were you
know Ruby's sexuality or Batwoman
sexuality this was going to be an out
character yeah a lot of people grabbed
on to that so being a part of a show
like that where you are opening this up
to potentially new fans
yeah the sort of new version of what
we're all very familiar with what was
your take on that you know I think that
in 2019 anything pushes the boundaries
and makes people you know think about
the world in which we live in you know
because we unfortunately do live in a
world that is is not a lot at the time
gay-friendly it's you know we have a lot
of problems in the world just now with
you know a certain guy in the White
House
and so anything that reinforces the you
know the this anti prejudice is a good
thing and you know it sends out a great
message for young girls who may be
struggling with sexuality and they have
a positive image on the screen for them
but it's not I mean it's not doesn't
define Ruby it doesn't define the show
yes she's gay the character and that's a
great positive image to send out but
it's about much more than that
it's it's you know it's an action you
know there's one of DC Comics is best
kind of stories and you know it's
credibly exciting I'm sure do you have a
you were talked about your version in
this show of Gotham aside from this
which version of Gotham do you sort of
gravitate towards that has come before
you yes good question well I watched the
series of Gotham which I thought was
fantastic I loved it
and the actors were all great in the
story it was great I think that I mainly
concentrated on the Christopher Nolan
version we actually also film in Chicago
or we film mostly in Vancouver but we go
to Chicago as well for a lot of the
exteriors and not more than I mean the
locations in Chicago are fantastic but
the tone of that was quite dark and
she's really managed to create I don't
know how she's done it because she's
incredibly talented but she's managed to
create a show that you know spread the
CW but it has so many shades in it and
different tones in it and it's it pulls
you this way and it pulls you that way
and it's not without its controversy and
it has its moments of real darkness and
pain and emotional reaction to you know
things have happened in the past that
come up and the present and it's it's a
heck of a ride I think and are you
interested or how interested in you are
this new version of Gotham which is
Joker Joaquin Phoenix
Oh me yeah yeah well wacky my love where
I've known because that's yet another my
man was quite a few things but yeah I
think it were working as a phenomenal
actor and I really want to see Joker I'm
not sure what the background of the
story is because I know it's a
standalone Joker story
I don't know how he's connected to the
the DC Comics world but he must be in
some respect but oh yeah very excited to
see why Kim playing Joker and you
getting sort of back into a world of you
know DC and comics as soon as that
happens the Wolverine stories start
coming back again which was how long ago
now many years ago I mean it's
incredible that people still want to
talk about it isn't it incredible though
that says something though well the one
thing I will says I think Hugh Hugh
Jackman is it was a terrific ruling I
would have been a different movie but I
think he is t's terrific I love the
story that you said no or what was that
did I did say no I said no three times
and they were like you gotta play
Wolverine I was like and then I sort of
met Bryan and I said okay I'll do it and
then I don't know what happened just the
the Tom was reluctant to let me go and
do it because we hadn't quite finished
and listen it was one of these things
that the scheduling was was difficult it
was you know it was difficult to
scheduling but I think they could have
made it work if they wanted to if
someone had wanted to but it was
restrained for everyone at fox but you
know it's one of these things and I went
on do other things and I'm alive and I'm
working and I'm really happy I was kind
of reluctant at the time to do it
because of you know what I was doing at
the time but um you know I think that
the this like because wool the x-men
when it when I read it originally it had
a great heart had a Great backstory to
it and I saw if I was able to do
something like that I was interested in
that and I kind of was offered a couple
of other things I was like I'm not
really sure about that but you know when
this came up when Batwoman came up and
they spoke to me about the character of
Jacob and why they wanted me to play him
I kind of listened and and I was you
know I was really taken in and Caroline
and you know Marcus see a guy he
directed the pilot and the second
episode as well we were very persuasive
and I'm really glad I did to it cuz I'm
having a great time and before I let you
go being in this world and on this show
you know now that for the rest of your
life you could spend it traveling from
convention to convention to conventions
that's right do you know what there's a
lot worse things to be done
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much thank you